let's look at the X and the y
axis these axes are used to recognize a
point on one plane one single plane this
plane is called the cartisian
plane as we can see the cian plane is
divided into four parts or
regions this one this one this one and
this one each of them is called a
quadrant the quadrants are named in a
particular order which we have to
strictly
follow this region is the first quadrant
in the first quadrant as we can see the
X as well as the Y coordinates are
positive moving in the anticlockwise
direction we name this quadrant the
second
quadrant in this quadrant the x
coordinates are negative while the
y-coordinates are
positive so remember for the first two
quadrants the y-coordinates are
positive moving in the anticlockwise
direction this is the third quadrant
where the X as well as the Y values are
negative this region is the fourth
quadrant the x coordinates are positive
and the Y coordinates are
negative does that mean that every point
on the plane will lie in any one of the
quadrants let's mark a few points on the
plane and see which quadrants they lie
in let's assume I Mark point a here this
point lies in the second quadrant so we
write a to here point a lies in the
second
quadrant let's assume I Mark point B
here this point is in the first quadrant
we write B first here Point C is marked
here as it lies in the the third
quadrant we write c 3 and this is point
D it is in the fourth
quadrant now let's look at something
interesting what about this point e
which quadrant does it lie in first
quadrant or the second one we say that
point e lies on the Y
AIS what about Point F here yes Point F
lies on the x- axis
what does this tell us it means that
each point on a plane lies either on one
of the Axis or in one of the
quadrants